you want to start a show called
man-at-arms art of war which is about a
show featuring iconic weapons from
memorable scenes in pop culture from
movies to videogames to comics the TV
shows you reach out for somebody with
334 IMDB credits that includes films
like machete machete kills from dusk
till dawn heat and obviously also
Breaking Bad from television the
legendary actor Danny Trejo here's to do
good to see you sir q how are you great
thank you for coming in here before we
get to your show and we get to
everything else I want to talk about
your fandom you you're you're from Echo
Park here in Los Angeles California on
here Echo Park I was about 13 then I got
in trouble in Iowa I got sent to Texas
and then I came back and my mom and dad
bought a house out in the valley
Oklahoma right I grew up see you said
you got sent to Texas Rich's yeah it's
called an out-of-state release it was
kind of like they kicked you out yo
how'd you get into acting how'd you get
all that was through a friend I was
trying to be an extra and I was working
with this one kid and he kind of said
come on down you know we've got a
problem in 1985 cocaine was it was a big
problem I went down I started working
with him and I ran into a friend of mine
named Eddie bunker who was a writer and
he asked me if I was still boxing and I
said I'm training I don't want to get
hit a face anymore buddy and so I
started they asked me if I wanted to
train an actor how to bounce and I said
what's it paid and he said 320 a day and
I said how bad you want to sky beat up
about that much money in tow
he said no no you got to be real careful
this actors a little high-strung might
shock you for 320 bucks give him a stick
it up for free yes I started training an
actor named Eric Robert all about Eric
Roberts and the director so I could hand
words saw that Eric respected me or what
sure and now would do what I asked him
to do so he hired me the director was a
guy named Andrei Konchalovsky
and I remember everybody kept saying
he's not saying Andrei make him say and
then suddenly he became a member of the
Screen Actors Guild and Eric Roberts is
I mean he's taken some beatings he has
resigned lost of I he's lost him he's
got he has taken some serious beatings I
was inmate number one for five years now
when you so you were boxing when you
were in San Quentin yeah what you didn't
quit in Folsom fellas so what was your
what was what was your classic I was
lightweight and Walter a champion a very
institution okay so what do you think of
this match between McGregor and
mayweather nice great I think it's great
I think it's just it's another fight and
I think he is beat McGregor
and Diaz is a boxer so I think Freud
could definitely outbox him you know now
McGregor hits hard and but he loses two
of his his assets he loses grappling and
he loses his kicks demonstrated us so so
now Floyd off Floyd's I'd do what he
does dancing here the difference between
Floyd Mayweather and a lot of fighters
is Floyd Mayweather there's a boxer and
that's like playing chess against
somebody's playing checkers well what do
you make of the Alvarez triple G fight
what do you think about that actually
fun to watch as we fun to watch I think
Alvarez is ready for now you know he
wasn't ready for Mayweather when he
fought me was a kid and we'd me and
George Lopez shout out in the audience
and actually just I would tell him I
watch his left watch his right was it
because you can tell what Alvarez was
gonna do just a kid in and uh but that's
wouldn't be a good fight well George
Lopez is a big Raider fan does that make
you greater or you RAM or what would you
want are you catching the ran since I
used to sneak into the Coliseum in the
50s and uh you know the Dutchman deal
big a norm Van Brocklin number 11 a
favorite player of all time he played
out
1950-51 so you went back to the Coliseum
last year and we didn't miss a whole
game I mean when autumn we went to we
got a deal to take our taco truck into
the into the stadium so you know I would
go in with the taco truck and so I'm
cooking and then I see you would go
sneakin in en so how how and it looks
the same right a Coliseum yeah just the
security is a lot more like how well
21st century now right yeah 21st century
but you were there with the fearsome
foursome Ruta forum with deacon jones
and the neuronal you ever act with
Merlin Olsen did that ever happen no I
just love those rosey Grier knew him you
met them but I never really did anything
okay Danny Trejo here in the Rich Eisen
show studio I want to take a break and
talk to you about your Dodger fandom and
then some of your movies and some of
your recollection of all that and
obviously what you're doing for the El
Rey Network 844 204 which is the number
two dollop Danny Trejo is here on the
Rich Eisen show studio we're back in 60
seconds Morton
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Chris Brockman with Danny Trejo bringing
doughnuts here he's totally Danny he's
unfocused you are you've gone off the
rails over not even paying attention I'm
telling you the problem the problem that
we have with the fritter is that after
you eat three then you're down on
fifteen main begging for Court why did
you create a donut in coffee shop and
we're looking from we love the police
you know and uh and then uh I always
tried to make donuts you know but it's
really hard to make it at home and uh
when the the place called donut time on
the corner of of a Highland and Santa
Monica Boulevard when that closed the my
two business partner Jeff and ash
they're kind of just said hey what do
you think it's a great idea and we we
have it post mates to the house all the
time the kids dig it and if you're in
town check it out is our website that
people can go to
ah we got it good you get on the card
right there Brockman that you just got
right there for trails donuts I died off
your shop all right we'll get that
information out shortly here on the show
which is your favorite credit you got
three hundred and thirty four of them
which is your favorite movie that you
were part of Danny Trejo well I would
have loved my Chet day even if I wasn't
in it
interesting great movie is Robert
Rodriguez and then uh but Mike the first
one that really kind of I did a movie
called heat with with Robert De Niro and
Al Jean you know and that kind of like
said wow you're like a real actor now
well that was unbelievable just just
meeting those so funniest I work with
Robert De Niro on aa heat I just
couldn't keep my eyes off his like under
the guy right and when my son met him my
son Gilbert I say Gilbert Robert De Niro
and bothers my son Gilbert Robert De
Niro goes hi Gilbert my son goes you
talking to me I'm nine years old I think
Gilbert you didn't see that movie you
can use the comedy
because you never showed your kid
Natalie driver at a sign okay so that's
why I got to go I gave a given nightmare
baby from dusk till dawn today tonight
when my eyes went in the pool pocket my
daughter jumped her six she jumped up in
the in the theater went oh that was so
cool why how does the Nero react to a
nine year olds nobody laughs you know
even Gilbert a good friends and then uh
and then when we did bachata he did
watch it there for me and I ran into him
and he was saying late you you number
one cuz I'm number one on the call
number one no no so take I just did a
good I guess isn't coffee miss it is he
still mister you that's fantastic
how did you get involved with Breaking
Bad I mean that was called they called
you Gloria my agent said uh you might do
one of Hollywood's first and I said
what's that ins isn't Breaking Bad wants
you to cross the desert on a tortoise
none it's got to be a pretty big
tortoise well it's just your head is
hollow is like no one else has done it
but okay where where is the head of
Tortuga really they oh they owe that to
me still really lose your still owe it
to me just like uh what's his name I did
Conair he still owes me the arm your arm
your ebooks
rock camera one of my arm molds so
Bruckheimer owes you an arm on vince
gilligan owes you a head
okay so we're piecing this together
right pretty soon pretty soon we'll have
old bridge all the whole body now it's
funny Luis Guzman who you know he's been
on this show
the his head from traffic yeah
Soderbergh gave him the head yeah and
that he puts that he said he puts it in
the passenger seat of his car so he can
get into the HOV Lane a rock-climber to
hear that why don't the arms going to
work for that I think Gilligan hang the
head of Tortuga
that in the front seat there are TV on
radio and as we put it up on TV there it
is right there there's Louise's head
from Rome he's great I mean I'm sure
you've worked with absolutely everybody
I'm yeah we including Will Ferrell right
for MA anchorman you're an addict I
understand makes the gutters funny that
guide means it's almost like a curse cuz
you can't walk into the room without do
laughing yeah he just has his oral
laughter he's not I wouldn't say the
haughty guy right he just makes you
laugh have you ever Danny Trejo been in
a romantic comedy or anything like that
have you done it was a romantic comedy
other are the love scene and Conair no
not no not the same is Shari Bay Bay
that was no I was a nice guy in that oh
by the way that could I could not have
written a better answer to that quality
knock on air that is fantastic
man of men-at-arms art of war on El Rey
Network you are the host it's every
Thursday night at 8:00 Eastern Time it
premiered earlier this month so you're
showing off um I guess this one weapons
from there being made it's kind of it's
what I like like it better than like
most weapons choses it's kind of a
history lesson with a lot of fun than
with uh it was not just somebody safe
talking about the is they show you how
it's made you know and and what it was
used for you know and a lot of people
don't know that one of the reasons that
the Mongols were so um so big that's a
joke you what was the fact that they
developed the one boat of the reverse
curved bow and it could shoot 820 feet
it would still with a lot of powers and
they could shoot it from a horse so so
what is it do you have any weapons from
any of your films that you still have
and your I guess your trophy case if you
will or your garage or anywhere or no
you haven't kept holds that atmosphere
you got a machete and sequins inside
your it's Wow lining your shirt my
designer oh my god
the designer of my clothes ah gee memo
he always puts them in my shirts or so I
love going through the airport saying
all right you got my shampoo but I got
my money does that work with good Oh
maybe is Cody Bellinger's back involved
in any of these weapons or wigs back
there certainly wielding that weapon
right now for for your Dodgers well what
do you what do you think of the Dodgers
Chani I just love them I you know I love
all Los Angeles do you even say you know
who you for the Lakers the kind of boom
on the both la beans on there the same
thing now we got the charger I'm a
die-hard Rams fan you know I mean I will
stab myself in the eye for the Rams Wow
but but now we got the Chargers so yeah
so the only game that's going to be
tough and is when the when when they
play each other in the Super Bowl just
like what's the point maybe in the new
stadium let's just see if we can stadium
now listen they're trying to I want to
do my dream is to get a tray host
Cantina in that new stadium I think
they've got space for it I've imagined
it to sing it yeah I mean it's taken
Larry you're on that alright
yeah Larry not what's the website Larry
for for for Danny's Donuts here we've
had trails Donuts dot-com okay those to
us TR e Jo
yeah s Donuts comm correct very good how
are we spelling Donuts deal ugh you know
I'll end you to your question to GH Cleo
and you TL and ul D let u GS you nuts
Trejo Kuna if I can say funny Joel and I
can
and I say that I guess I think that I
guess I just said that and we caught
your when you throw the first pitch at
Chavez Ravine oh he caught it
yeah he caught it the second bounce was
the first bounce but I threw it from
behind the did you stand on the mound no
no I flew over behind them out because I
didn't want to I wanted disrespect - it
was a [ __ ] what do you mean you stood
behind them out yeah like you behind the
mound yeah what's it mean I did it once
and I stood on top of them out is that
is that disrespect well I don't know it
just seemed like God and those are like
real pitchers you know you know who
caught the ball
yeah was a little known at the time
reliever who was wearing a number in the
high 90s Kenley Jansen I caught my first
pitch and then suddenly he became the
closer so his success where he's
striking out and walking nobody and
making millions of dollars it all
started with my first all right that's
the way yeah you run Elda you
little-known facts with rich decides yes
and he says by the way you did throw
from behind a man and Puig took the
bouncy being but then he brought it back
in first over like actors went like this
ha ha ha yeah mine mine would have the
left-hander Danny on my pitch the
left-hander would have been fooled by
the off-speed action and then the
right-handed hitter would have been hit
by the ball and that's Kenley Jansen
catching the ball number 74 got it so
funny because I was practicing with a
kid named anima tickle who played for El
Camino high school and he just graduates
going to San Diego State ok there you
comfortable now let's watch him fly ok
man-at-arms art of war on El Rey Network
every single Thursday night at 8:00
Eastern Time trio's Donuts calm I'm tone
you want this stuff Brockman how many of
you had three already over two and a
half say they were tilted two and a half
oh don't don't lie just round up man
just be proud it own it I find higher 93
they're great old they're great I'm
going to have a fourth here in the break
by the way that's a new drop Danny Trejo
saying they're great homes
that's a drop here on the red Johnson
show we're back with Garrett car news
from the Oakland Raiders front that's
next year on the rejoice the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint